hmm  okay  that's the one  [Music]  i am hillary the chef to cuisine at cut  beverly hills today i'm grilling two  steaks building a dry age new york strip  steak that dries for 35 days the dry age  is 48 that's actually a pretty good deal  it's a great deal the other steak is a  japanese new york strip 25 an ounce so  what separates this 25 an ounce steak  this japanese beef is from miyazaki  prefecture these cattle have been bred  for thousands of years i have a  certificate that tells me all about this  animal you trace it back 80 years so who  are we eating today i don't want to give  this a name we're about to eat the food  yeah but it's a beautiful product so we  should respect it exactly